does he lie to you
oh i'm a liar god you know i'm neil
brennan was on our podcast yesterday and
he said the the truest thing i'd ever
heard about bobby which is he lies about
everything except for the things he
needs to lie about yeah like
for example it's like he lies about
everything that he shouldn't even need
to lie about but if you ask him hey dude
how much money do you have in your bank
he'll tell you the exact specifics and
you're like you shouldn't you should lie
about that
ask me if i saw top gun did you see top
gun no
but i did yeah last night was really
good
but that's what i would do at a club
like
i would just lie about that about things
and you were so convincing that was
amazing how you did that
i didn't even ask you guys you want
something to drink or no that's fine i
once asked his therapist i was like is
this pathological lying she's like no
it's like it's like a leisure lying it's
just for fun somehow he finally let me
ask you something as a re as as the
person the most important person in the
relationship that you've had how long
have you guys been together ten years
almost
so lying is not a honesty is not an
issue with you
um i would say that i can sort of
read through his
[ __ ] bluffs at this point like i'm a
master i'm a i'm a lie jedi but does he
do what he just did like will he say two
seconds later that i'm just kidding i
was lying uh no i just know that he's
full of [ __ ] oh okay is that what you
love about him
for the more important life things of
course i i i sit him down i snap my
fingers and say okay we cannot this has
to be a meaningful
talk we're having right now no lies yes
i don't lie about um i love the raising
the hand he raises the hand it's like a
class
101 go i don't lie about serious [ __ ]
like if for instance like i i would
never cheat on her i would never like um
like i would never say i went to the
doctor and i found out i have cancer
like to [ __ ] with her emotions in that
way you know well early on in the
relationship you did yeah early on in
the relationship you told me you had
cancer wait what can i can i just tell a
small story and it's don't be you know
it
worth nine years removed from this story
go ahead no feelings about it go ahead
you know the story she's gonna tell no
oh you have no idea just a variety it
could be anything just a giant grudge
i'm holding but no no
deep resentment
go ahead
um so um in the beginning of our
relationship i think i had lost my phone
one day and he was like here i have like
uh he gave me his bat phone or like a
phone but that was still linked to his
other phone
so but he i didn't know that it was
still linked to his other phone so
messages that he was sending back and
forth with a woman were popping up on
this phone that he lent me because he's
an idiot
i thought you said you'd never cheat i
never he didn't cheat he didn't cheat
okay but you know it was like but i say
i say things to other women sometimes
and so he had said something
questionable to a woman who was an
attractive tell me what it was you said
um she was like you're a king and then
you replied with i want to raw dog you
oh my god
which is a a radio station on seriously
right yeah yeah that's all that's all i
know about it i want you to hear the
comedy that i love
well condoms don't fit me
so harry smells like a minion yes that's
small oh is this a pg show i shouldn't
be saying no no no
you can even say [ __ ] oh perfect all
right howie i don't like the way you
said that but anyway well he said well
basically that's what you said
it was a hard t i didn't like it i
didn't like the hard thing
she don't have a problem with the c
she's fine
and so i'm in the other room just
minding my own business and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is this so i go in well
you're not minding your own business
well it's i would love to mind my own
business except this thing is popping up
so i go to him and i'm like bobby
why are you doing this and he was like
that's not me
that's not me that's not me he's like i
didn't write that i would never write
that and i'm like bobby
give me your phone these two things
match because that's not me that's not
me and he walks away
right
if you just deny right
she'll have to take me to court it
worked though they're still together
yeah we're still together yeah how did
you resolve that we never did we never
did exactly right now it wasn't me still
you mean i'm i'm standing by it it
wasn't me it wasn't him it wasn't him
howie it wow yeah reality is subjective
you're like shaggy didn't shaggy have
that song
yeah that's a song and that's nine years
ago that's before the song so you're
saying you came up with the idea for the
song yeah
yeah that's what you're saying here's
another thing that i don't do now is
it's like i don't lend her my uh ipad
oh look at her look at you the reason
why i don't let her my ipad because it's
like i don't i didn't realize that your
phone and your ipad are linked as well
right right so if she sometimes her
ipad's dead right and she'll go um can i
watch movies on your ipad and i used to
go yeah go ahead but then it's like i
realized that she could read my messages
and stuff right right they don't have to
still uh you still uh
no you message no
no no no no
he's a good boy i'm a good boy
[Music]